what if you just ended up throwing
everything I guess we got robbed I'll
tell you exactly what would happen this
[ __ ] would go to [ __ ] Target a World
Market or some [ __ ] and violence I go to
the airport with Nikki it's four bags
and Nikki can't even handle two cops
Plus World Market this [ __ ] has 17
cards she's like
[Laughter]
straight
to take a card she's got like 17 cards
in the daisy chain all the way through
the whole [ __ ] thing he's spending
1400 on pillows and stupid [ __ ] trays
and [ __ ] take the pillows when she's
gone and toss them out no she'll know
it's me I'm the one who [ __ ] about it
I'm the one who's smiling I'm like we
got robbed bring in like a friend and
they complain about the goddamn pillows
Bart please you do it no dude find out
who she idolizes in life and make
friends with them have them become a
poker player yeah like a poker champ
have him walk in the first thing he says
is what the [ __ ] are all these pillows
if you want to make it to the big
leagues you're getting rid of these
[ __ ] pillows